mr. yonkers 300 billion euro plus
investment plan designed to stimulate
growth and reduce unemployment has been
public knowledge for weeks at this
week's plenary session the commission
president shared more details the
purpose of this new fund will be to
invest in those member states most hit
by the economic downturn it would be
linked to structural reforms he said
hoping for hefty public as well as
private investor contributions for
programs that could include telecoms
digital technology and energy and
transport infrastructure this week's
summit of heads of state and government
in Brussels will be a test of you hope
that European Council if tomorrow will
indicate its intention to contribute not
only words not only parolee parolee I
need money for some Emmy Peas member
state hesitation and the decision is the
problem that needs to be overcome what
we need now is an ambitious response by
the council on thursday and friday and i
have to tell you the Dellavedova I have
seen the the project of conclusions I
know Cola lights call a light you know
what it is while the discounts alight if
member states get behind it it could be
the first stage of a bigger process if
it addresses one key function how we
unlock the trillions of euros of private
money that could be invested in EU
member states to create jobs and growth
in the midst of the crisis MEP s have
been looking for models of reform in
hard times Ireland is one latvia another
but they're they're cautious about
expectations of miracles there is no
such thing as a golden bullet the key is
will the private sector follow and I am
quite certain that the private sector
will not follow unless member states
redouble their efforts on these
so-called structural reforms the
Socialists took a different tack
believing the economic stimulus comes in
social structural reforms unemployment
rates opportunities for young people
education number of graduates ok those
structural reforms I think will help
pursue the objective of making the
investments function so they should go
hand in hand if it's only austerity
measures then they will not work also on
the agenda the council you
crane things have been quieter in
eastern Ukraine in the past week but as
M eps pointed out the situation is still
in century